dans les rues de roseaux tels des âmes
errantes la population 2015 épuisé
assoiffés mais en toute humilité et de
la dignité
elle rend grâce d'être encore en vie ce
mot jawad ayons des cyclones à la vie -
mais ça l'a même - thann maria di kappa
les oies les maria ou ois chérif la cour
des noues matin les canons comme quoi j
vie ni baisser pour maîtriser a pour
intention catégorie five saut mais ses
body moitié mort mais ces maudits venez
vivre des mois la sortie de la capitale
l'inconnu alors des équipes de
reconnaissance partent à la conquête de
petits bouts de territoire devenu
méconnaissable soufrière petite ville de
6000 habitants
jadis touristique aujourd'hui un étrange
r2 vallée de la mort l'ouragan maria a
été impitoyable
ouais tout ça c'était placement sur
sarthe et eminem avait balancé sa mine
1000 à la kawa la montée ni anti
business d'antibiotiques tout bête -
poule
bref cochon tout bagaya tout marianne
oural et maniema délicatement metal m
mon style peine lajaumont p 2 600 dans
la boutique la can cinq jours coupés du
monde sans eau sans nourriture sans
électricité avec des bébés des femmes
enceintes et des malades
en fait ce premier contact à tout prix
sorti de cette épreuve chaque veut
parler raconter dit sa souffrance
las olas d'époisses ambiguïté et 10 me
sont vingt ans encartée va qui a dû suer
tous contents barakani homme libre lui
boycottant 14 wata knight a croisé et
vert oms agglo combats ces 48 pour moi
c'est un monde suit en un an le nouveau
woody pourra les mots pour le moins
élevé il a et par année on l'apprend de
produire le côté disait nous disait
parce qu'on sait pas ce qu'on me dit un
calme et voisine de la ville de
soufrière deux autres villages forme
district de 10000 habitants
du côté de la mer caraïbe on y dénombre
une victime une femme emportée par la
mer mais dans les autres villages encore
isolés l'autre côté de l'île nul ne le
sait à quoi s'attendre